one down 99 more wells in Africa to go
you're going to love this video some
people are actually mad about this video
of Mr Beast and his team building 100
wells in Africa why because they hate
capitalism through his videos Mr Beast
has given millions of dollars to
charitable causes making him the most
successful Creator on YouTube also
attracting haters you might remember the
huge backlash earlier this year when Mr
Beast funded treatment for 1,000 blind
people so they could see again but in
response the Socialist magazine current
affairs called Mr Beast demented and
capricious feminist News website Jezebel
accused him of profiting from inequity
that's backward Mr Beast is voluntarily
relieving inequity and profiting as a
result it's capitalism it's a good thing
in fact it's produced a massive
reduction in poverty worldwide let
people make money by helping others and
everyone is better off there's nothing
demented about it